all right Internet once and for all I'm
laying this to rest I'm going to tell
you the exact color of that damn thing
white and gold black and blue it's
actually a different color entirely
called who gives a I consulted a
kid who had that absurdly huge Crayola
cran box that no one actually needs so
you know that's legit that's the correct
answer
Lucas so focus is a movie starring Will
Smith and Margot Robbie that's right
Deadshot and Harley Quinn are in a movie
together
Will Smith is this expert con artist he
kind of takes Margot Robbie under his
wing because she's like maverick from
Top Gun in the world of scheming people
it's like oh you have skill but it's
unfocused so I'm gonna focus it in the
movie called focus so after that's a
movie about conning and being a con
artist and scamming which is really
interesting I was like this could be the
next Ocean's eleven for the first half
of this movie house like this might be
the next Ocean's eleven for me I like a
good con movie you know we all do and I
love seeing people who are the best at
their crafters to see where Will Smith's
just training her it's just like it's
hands-on it's like you do this and
they're not gonna see this you do this
they're not gonna see this
he's just lifting watches and purses off
of her you're like that's really cool
that he's that good at it there's this
one scene in the movie that was
remarkably intense and I was like that's
what I want to see in a movie about
conning people then scene intermission
whole new Act and after that I was like
it's not as interesting as the first act
of this movie I don't even know if it's
the first act it's like the first half
of the first half of this movie is the
movie focused about Will Smith is a con
artist and he trains Margot Robbie to be
a con artist and they're the best of
what they do and then the second half of
this movie is like focused - it's like
the sequel that's not as good as the
first movie the job is bigger than last
time the stakes are bigger than last
time the con is bigger than last time
but it's just crammed into one movie but
it ultimately became about Margot Robbie
and Will Smith's relationship and like
us to love you but I kind of don't
you're like oh man can you please take
notes from your title and focus if I was
that interested in the first half of
this movie which was ultimately a bunch
of small Kong's baby they could have had
the whole movie be about a bunch of
small cons and that would have been fine
I mean the performances are great I
thought Will Smith was really good that
dude is charismatic as hell he's
charismatic as hell in this movie Margot
Robbie's great I'm feeling really good
about her being Harley Quinn I really am
I can't wait to see her rocker she was
great in wolf of wallstreet she's great
here she shows us she's more than just a
pretty face she's a pretty face who can
act and then ultimately the end of this
movie happens you know they're gonna be
twisting turns on her conne movie that's
just how it's gonna go down by the end
of this movie I walked out going I don't
buy it I'm not looking for possible I'm
not even looking for believable but the
fact that the movie gives you has do at
least lineup to make you buy it if it's
gonna be unbelievable
we'll make it unbelievably consistent
this movie was not unbelievably
consistent you walk out going I don't
buy that and that because the dialogue
between them and them in the end focus
was a little more unfocused and a movie
should be if it's gonna rock the title
focus I loved Margot Robbie I loved Will
Smith they were great together they have
good chemistry together - the first half
of this movie was great I loved the cons
I loved how good I loved how immersive
this movie is and bringing you into the
con world you feel like you're learning
the trade - which is actually pretty
select and the second half of this movie
slows down I feel like it bit off a
little more than a kachou it tries to be
so clever that it overreaches it's like
nah you just stop that you're slapping
his hand down you're like don't do that
you're not ready for that don't do that
in the end I will say focus was still a
good time no alcohol required there so
focus have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
con movie of all time whatever you
thought whatever it is comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more